liberal Democrat Senator John fedman has
just lambasted the government of South
Africa for encouraging and perpetrating
genocide against white people wait what
and now let's also talk about that now
we're talking about genocide and now
South Africa now is now bringing that
kind of a a trial maybe South Africa
maybe ought to sit this one out when
they're talking about
criticizing fetman made those comments
in order to make a different point in of
Israel's actions against Gaza so it
wasn't totally out of the blue but still
fetterman's comments seem to suggest
that we are now officially living in a
'90s comedy movie in which the
protagonist gets hit on the head and
suddenly changes all his views about
everything marvelous news for two
reasons one Senator Federman is clearly
making great strides in recovering from
his health issues and two because as
fetterman's brain function improves he
is becoming increasingly right-wing